new record net migration figures have
provoked anger among some conservatives
because of the failure to deliver on a
key Manifesto pledge from the 2019
election there's also frustration from
those outside the party who campaign for
Britain to leave the EU among them Nigel
farage former leader of the brexit party
ukip and now a presenter on GB news he's
conceded that brexit has failed so where
did it all go wrong and did he and other
politicians over promise on the benefits
Nigel farage thank you so much for
coming on the show today now you are the
most famous advocate of brexit perhaps
vying with Boris Johnson and you
recently made a stark admission that
brexit had failed do you want to
apologize to voters for telling them
that we should leave the EU if it was a
failure well let's finish the sentence
brexit has failed under the Tories yes I
mean look in constitutional terms brexit
is a success we've left the European
Union we've reversed the status quo and
the reason we won the referendum the
reason the turnout was 10 higher than
all the analysts thought it was going to
be was this idea that the population
explosion in Britain caused by
immigration was diminishing people's
quality of life and and frankly that is
completely down to this government
setting the level at which people can
come for work permits basically at the
level of minimum wage
regulation immigration do you take any
responsibility
for some of the failures of brexit or
some of the promises that were made in
the campaign that were not realized any
responsibility absolutely none no
absolutely none I was very very clear
very very clear this was about reducing
numbers it was about moving to an
Australian style point system where you
set the barriers and you set the levels
so that you get genuinely skilled
migration and willfully Boris Johnson
willfully lowered those salary levels
and we've also seen this explosion of
foreign students coming to Britain being
allowed to bring dependents but the
thing is when people think of brexit
they do think of you and Boris Johnson
because you made lots of promises as
well in that campaign not really no no I
I was the one making the least number of
promises you said in June 2016 that um
you could get migration to under 50 000.
of course but I wasn't in charge look
you know had we been a European country
with proportion representation you know
I would have been in a position of
authority
to work with government to try and
achieve this as it is the irony was
here's the irony the day after the
referendum the very few very people I'd
fought against for 25 years were still
in power and so what you've got and even
in 2019 you've got a government that was
given an 80-seat majority but here's the
key they never really believed in it
okay well look you also made the
promises to the British people about
controlling borders laws having trade
deals that U.S trade deal is nowhere to
be seen none of it happened no I wonder
why that is I wonder why that well I
wonder why that is but does this make
my question actually was does this make
the public more cynical about
politicians like you that promise these
things that don't I don't do you reflect
on that I can promise you if you look at
the polling this week done by yougov
I've got it here brexiteers that are
disappointed I'm one of them you know
I'm in that number 37 of brexit Voters
are disappointed
of that 37 75 percent lay it firmly and
squarely at the door of this government
let me put it another way then do you
think the public might think twice about
believing what you say next time no no
but they might think twice about what
the conservatives say next time
and I think you know I think a lot of
this
is down to a breach of trust
between what has been promised to voters
and elections and what's being done and
what would be your solution in the short
term would you close off the borders and
have worker shortages in the UK to in
order to drive net migration down if
that meant if that meant there was a
realistic chance of people finding
somewhere to live
school for their kids to go to that was
local people getting access to the
National Health Service then yes of
course so you would you would shut the
borders I didn't say well you would you
use the number of workers even if that
meant shortages
okay you cannot go on look before 2004
when this really kicked off right
cabbages were not rotting in the fields
of Lincolnshire
elderly people were not being left alone
in old people's homes we managed to do
all of this and we've now become
addicted to cheap unskilled foreign
imported labor we have to reverse that
process well let's talk about
the execution because it seems to me
that a lot of people see you as the
biggest cheerleader of brexit it hasn't
worked out in the way no that perhaps
was promised to the British people it
hasn't worked out the way it hasn't
worked out in the way that I spent
nearly 30 years captivating for but but
you won't take responsibility for that
but I wasn't getting the power I wasn't
given the power so that it's not on me
golf right I wasn't in a position so
let's talk about the execution because
let's try to get to the truth of this I
think it's fascinating about how it
could have gone better right because you
think don't you that there was another
way that brexit could have worked for
Britain and it seems to me that your
model would have been decisive political
decision for the country to diverge from
the EU slash taxes reduce regulation
build a Singapore on Thames that that's
what you wanted I never said I know I
never quoted the Singapore on tennis but
does anyone I do think I think so much
of what we do as a government and what
the European Union does as well
is to meet the demands and needs of the
lobby groups for giant companies
there's a sector of our economy that has
been left out of this debate completely
self-employed small Traders those
businesses they were the ones that voted
brexit they were the ones that wanted an
easing a lifting of the burdens and
actually it's from those millions of
people that you get genuine economic
growth that's
at the moment it seems that we're in the
whilst of all worlds because we haven't
taken the brexit opportunities perhaps
that that you visit but but that did
involve massive Divergence deregulation
slashing taxes trying to make the UK
economically competitive no we didn't
need to slash taxes remember actually
one of the few things that George
Osborne got right is we did bring
corporation tax down to a reasonable and
competitive level we've now gone we
we've now converged with France with our
corporation tax rates and you know one
of the worst things of all that's
happened and this is not being spoken so
you did want to cut Corporation taxes I
want to leave it where it was we had a
competitive corporation tax rate well we
don't with Ireland we'd all no Ireland
even more competitive and good for them
all right but but the the short-term
Necessities were not slashing taxes
post-brexit the short-term Necessities
were number one decisive political
action triggering article 50 the day
after the referendum had that been done
the trade deal with America would have
been concluded but because the
conservative party yes of course there
were some that campaigned for brexit but
the party itself hated the brexit result
we've had years of hesitancy and even
when they seem to finally get the
message they didn't get it they've never
ever as a party have believed in this
but this so what the PO it seems to me
that your vision of a pace brexit
Britain was almost the vision that Liz
truss had a completely uh for driving
the economy deregulating cutting taxes
trying to compete with the EU trade
helping the little people that was my
agenda helping the little people I
always fought for that I always stood
for that and it has not happened I guess
what I'm asking you what I'm trying to
get to is whether the project was sold
to the British people
in a way that wasn't going to come to
fruition and the actual real project was
what I'm talking about the only way it
would have worked well well I look I do
think and you don't really talk to the
British people about how it was going to
work I talked to the British people
about achieving Independence all right
and and there were two areas I repeat
this there were two areas that I thought
were easily deliverable the first was
reducing this massive population
increase into our country and the second
was to lift some of the burdens off the
backs of ordinary men and women going
out there trying to earn a living they
were the two two and you know something
they were realistic expectations of
those that voted brexit and they haven't
happened and
I mean frankly frankly I look at that I
look at that 2019 story Manifesto the
way it was put to the people and frankly
it was a big lie isn't partly the truth
of net migration that for economic
growth you need a level of net migration
oh listen I've been hearing this for a
quarter of a century all right you know
you know if increasing the British
population by 8 million people has added
you know a few Pips here and there a few
decimal points here and there to GDP so
blooming what there is something that is
far more important than the size of our
GDP there is something actually called
Community there is something called
quality of life in this country and
these are things these are things that
virtually nobody in Westminster even
talks about but they are very keenly
felt outside the M25 but you made it
sound so simple in that referendum
campaign and it wasn't simple was it it
was never going to be simple
like it was going to be a simple thing
to do well what you do it was never
going to be simple on the morning of the
24th of June 2016 you trigger article 50
you begin the process no one's saying it
was going to be simple but we made it
very very difficult because we had a
government full of remainers who didn't
believe in it and I am I mean to be
honest with you there's nobody more
disappointed than me in what this
government's done I'm furious I would
have loved to have been in a position of
responsibility but I wasn't
but you promise things as well in that
referendum
that you could never deliver I think
you'll find Boris Johnson and others
were the ones making you you said you
could get I I was looking to ask from
June before the vote June 2016 you said
we can get net migration down to 50 000.
yes of course now whether you want it's
a good name Boris Johnson of course
we'll look at that and say this I
believe this guy yes I believe this guy
yes I voted for it because of this guy
we could have got it down and this guy
let me down this guy didn't come with
the trees I wasn't if you put if they
put me in charge of it would have got to
30 000 a year no question about it but
they didn't
and so the problem we've got now is I I
you know I said brexit I said 10 years
ago I wanted to cause an earthquake in
British politics all right well we got
the earthquake we're still suffering the
aftershocks and we're all living with
the fractures well we're suffering the
aftershocks because
yes because Parliament and the
government have ignored the will of the
people they've ignored what was said in
that brexit referendum and so now
a bigger question emerges as to how
we're going to change politics in this
country ever look at it though and think
uh I I promise things to the British
people that I as a politician didn't
know if I could deliver I feel some
responsibility no because they're going
wrong no because they were never your
fault they were all no they were all
deliverable that's the point it wasn't
difficult to do that's the point maybe
they weren't as deliverable as you made
out as them to be for example with net
migration and it's awesome to Simply you
think if I'd been in charge would have
allowed foreign students to bring
dependents in do you think if I was in
charge we'd have set you know a level
when minimum wage levels break down the
migration Figures it's not just foreign
students it's also worker visas for
shortages in the economy it's Ukrainian
Refuge level but there's a number of
proponents in those net migration
figures some of which you need to pick
yes at the level of minimum wage that
was not the promise that was not the
deal
so we are where we are
and when it comes to you and and the
Reform Party of which you're the
president yeah
um they did terribly in the local
elections so what does that tell you
about your repeal ability now with the
public nearly four or five percent of
seats so it's very difficult to judge
whether they did well badly to be honest
um and you know building up a national
party political structure is not an easy
thing to do but
I think the gap between Westminster and
where people are is even bigger than it
was 10 years ago
I think there will be another Insurgency
in British politics whether it'll so
whether it'll be reform whether it'll be
me
whether we get a new Nick Griffin I
trust you you made all these promises
and I don't I don't think do you not
think that you might be a busted flush
on that as I said to you if you take the
Hugo polling this week of the 37 that
are disappointed by brexit 75 percent of
them fairly unsquarely at the doors of
the conservative party they're certainly
not laying it at my door and and if it's
not me and not reform then maybe we get
a Nick Griffin type figure maybe we get
genuinely the far right into British
politics something is going to change
this Gap is too big
do you genuinely think that you could
come back now and run a campaign as the
guy that's going to deliver a true
brexit given what's passed oh I think if
I stood again it would be a much more
revolutionary agenda than just brexit it
would be fundamental change to the
voting system do something people might
be watching this people that listen to
you and what you promised in 2016 about
how the country would change after
brexit and what has come to pass and
think I don't trust a thing this guy I
think no I think I think they'll share
my disappointment okay final question
will I see you back in Frontline
politics then in the next five years I
don't know I genuinely don't know I
haven't ruled it out I haven't ruled him
in if I could see
by doing it there was a really clear
achievable goal that I might well I
haven't worked that out yet
if we had
if we had a form
an electoral system that was
representative in some way well then it
would be much easier you you you brought
brexit to Britain and where you were the
chief cheerleader now brexit's in crisis
and your message to the British public
is it wasn't my fault
absolutely we've been let down very
badly by an entirely dishonest
establishment globalist and now remain
notorious some voters might look at and
think you were dishonest when you were
promising stuff that you could never
deliver you know what I might have got
things right I might have got things
wrong over my years in politics I would
like to think hand on heart I was never
dishonest okay Nigel farage thank you so
much